[Musique]
en attendant la ryder cup le week-end a
été riche en sport dans les yvelines
bonsoir michael et demi d'euros dans sa
galerie le monsieur sport de cette
rédaction de tv 60 minutes alors votre
émission le 7-8 plan reprend ce soir
juste après ce journal mais d'abord
nickel et ce sera un rendez vous
habituel chaque lundi dans le jt à vous
allez à nous faire part des principaux
résultats a dit oui ou non il y avait
notamment du rugby ce week-end dans le
département oui grigorian jouer ce
week-end le premier match du championnat
de fédérale 2 pour sa deuxième saison
consécutive dans cette division plaisir
a raté son entrée en lice les plaisirs
wa pas encore prêt physiquement et
tactiquement se sont lourdement inclinés
à domicile contre le marcquois rugby
score final 51 à xiii on écoute les
réactions au micro de notre journaliste
nicolas dans les impressions c'est
beaucoup d'amertume parce que c'est vrai
que c'est jamais agréable de commencer
la saison en prenant 50 points à la
maison
maintenant ça va nous mettre dans le
droit chemin nous mettre un peu de plomb
dans la tête vous ce faut se dire qu'il
ya du travail à faire et ça va être
comme ça tous les week-ends et comme
l'année dernière on lâchera rien on
mérite pas une telle défaite maintenant
quand on maîtrise aussi peu de chose à
un moment donné
la sanction est un peu obligatoire et
ouais notamment les 3 4 premiers essais
comprends c'est que des défauts de notre
parc que l'adversaire utilise à fond
voilà donc aucun problème
c'est logique après cette défaite
plaisir pointe à la dernière place du
championnat de fédérale 2 ils devront
absolument se rattraper le dimanche 16
septembre face à gennevillois et il n'y
avait pas que du rugby ce week-end
michael en football bien sûr l'équipe de
france qui jouait hier un match de
national league ont joué également la
première journée du championnat de d1
district on peut rien vous cacher un
grégory un tour d'horizon des résultats
à guyancourt débute par un match nul
contre eux à gargenville score final un
but partout
même résultat pour plaisir sur le
terrain de sartrouville de son côté à
maurepas n'a fait qu'une bouchée de
montesson en s'imposant à 6,1 à
l'extérieur un résultat qui leur permet
de prendre la tête du championnat
enfin le chesnay arrache le nul 3
partout sur le terrain douilles et le fc
mantois et avricourt se neutralisent 2
buts partout la 2e journée du
championnat sera programmée le 23
septembre prochain
enfin on finit à michael avec le
championnat de nationale 3 2 de football
avec un petit nouveau je crois voilà
charles itandje le nouveau gardien de
versailles versailles qui joue
versailles qui gagnent ils ont réalisé
une belle prestation sur le terrain en
s'imposant 2 buts à 1 dans un derby
vinoy contre les mureaux un résultat qui
permet au versailles et de grimper à la
6e place du classement avec un bilan de
deux victoires un nul et une défaite
prochain match le samedi à 22 7 ans
contre le blanc mesnil great merci
michael pour ce tour d'horizon et